I've sit down for a very large business
dinner a season of indulgence now
perhaps an uncomfortable memory I'm
halibut food coma moment as we have
eaten so much today we're having roast
leg of lamb homemade Yorkshire puddings
trifle for dessert but a new year with
four people on four different diets over
three weeks will test the realities of a
multi-billion pound dieting industry
what's the driving force what is it you
want to achieve my husband and I want to
have children I thinking I'm working on
borrowed time very much aware of the
long-term impact and and and and vanity
is why when I was pregnant yeah I was
lighter than I am now these are all skin
tags can you see the skin tags and this
tells me that there is a chance of
developing diabetes stage 1 a
consultation with weight management
specialist dr. Rogers Warren all four
are clinically obese but it's the news
each are subsequently given that shocks
there's a darkening of the axilla which
is armpit that tells me there's a
problem with insulin resistance for
Philip the possible early stages of
diabetes it certainly makes it real I'd
say it's not saying that I that has
actually been physically told me before
by a physician so I think it's something
that does make it touch home for Saphira
a high chance of diabetes and the risk
of infertility and that's worrying
because I wanted to lose weight so that
my husband and I can start having
children so if there's a risk that we
can't because of my weight that's just
devastating
so I'm going to have a listen to your
chest and feel your tummy Michelle very
high blood pressure alongside already
diagnosed diabetes she needs immediate
treatment complications of diabetes
could include kidney problems blindness
heart attack strokes chronic ulcers and
petitions the high blood pressure I've
never really had high blood pressure
before so that's definitely a new one
and the the possibility of getting
cancer through through weight gain is
frightening now listen to the back of
his chest and Howell it's similar
there's a high chance of developing type
2 diabetes cancers cirrhosis of the
liver and depression arthritis sleep
apnea so the number of serious problems
related to wait quite shocking i say i
didn't otherwise allow such thing that
was something that i was there it was
that it was such a serious problem but
um yeah that's something definitely
looking to pretty much straight away
awning figures released last year show
the number of obesity-related hospital
admissions rose from just under 30,000
in 2003 to over 290,000 in 2013 and
obesity costs the NHS 5.1 billion pounds
every year compare that with a UK diet
industry estimated to be worth over two
billion pounds an industry bombarding us
with dieting advice at every turn and
yet against a backdrop of an ever
increasing health service bill the
health secretary says part of the answer
lies in early prevention I think the
real area that we need to focus more on
his childhood obesity I think this is
shocking statistic that nine percent of
children enter primary school Abby's
clinically obese nineteen percent leave
primary school obese that is just not
acceptable and we have to do a lot more
the next stage is to pick one diet each
4 2015 4 Phillip with the threat of
diabetes it's now about securing the
future with his family Adele Robinson
Sky News